hey guys today we have this 2013 Nissan
Altima
we're going to be programming
a key a smart key using the out Tech
this is going to be all keys lost
and adding it
the car all right let's get to it
[Music]
all right let's start programming so
we'll be using the out Tech ikey820
as you can see
it's not working and
nothing's going on with this key
all right let's go ahead um
go to program key
program
oh this is not a touchscreen so just
okay
and then we're gonna go down scroll down
to Nissan
all the way down
a little bit more
There You Go Nissan press ok
then
let's go to um by vehicle
okay
then go to Ultima okay
then let's scroll down to 2013.
okay
I think this is keyless type two press
ok
turn the ignition off
well of course it's off it's not working
let's go off press ok
program keyless press ok
turn ignition off and turn emergency
light
standard
Hazard on
Swig this
up
then press ok
communicating
it says third ignition off and turn the
emergency light on or kilos will be
erased okay
we have that already
say pin code error
it's off
press ok
communicating
just press ok
let's try sync
communicating please wait
okay
press start the button once
the start button will light flash within
five seconds put the emblem side to the
bottom until the instrument is on
okay let's go
press that
key there there you go
instrumental on
I press and hold it then let's press ok
turn the ignition off
let's go ahead
and that off
there you go
press ok
program next key
no we only have one key Escape
press the start button once the start
button will flash within five seconds
put the emblems number one key to start
button okay
press it again
put the key in there
turned on again
and then press ok
turn the ignition off again
all right
starting off
then press ok
say success press ok
see if it's
go ahead
program keyless
turn the ignition off
it's off
okay communicating
so you can be okay
[Music]
let's start on ready
turn on
there you go
bye
press the key again
locked and unlock
there you go guys see that
foreign
keep pressing it
let's turn it on
press the key in there again
keyless is worse already
we'll see if we'll start the car
so it doesn't start the car yet so let's
go ahead
program keyless
edition of highlight
let's do the flasher on
press ok
communicating
okay I'm just gonna
lock this one real quick
then press ok
pin code error
I'm white
go to type one
let's try type one
two ignition off it is off
communicating program key
connection error
we go type two
the ignition off it is off
and program keyless
press ok
go press OK again
there you go
it's communicating now press start
button once the start button will Flash
let's do it again
hold it put the key there until it turn
on
that's turn on
and then let's press ok
turn the ignition off
one
it's off
press OK again
program this key no we only have one key
press start button again
put the key and then press it hold
there you go it turned on
and then it says press should be okay
complete press ok
ignition off one more time
and then let's press ok
say success
let's see what happened
turn it on
key again
turn around
and this turn on
so you can turn it off again
let's go ahead try to start the car
turn it on again
key
there you go
keep recognizing I'm just gonna keep
turning on and off
there you go
key registration complete
you just have to when you turn off the
car make sure you put the key
on there
so on the um
on the push button so this should be
okay now
lock unlock
let's press the brake
starts the car there you go guys
that's it
turn it off again
everything works now
so this one works with the out Tech
ikey820
not too bad takes like about I mean I
could have done it in less than five
minutes
um that's my first time using this
outtake for
Nissan and I barely use this programmer
um this is my backup
but it works and like what I said just
be patient
um
the thing is you have to put the key and
the push button every time
you press the button like but you have
to when you turn it on you have to hold
that
and when you turn it off you have to
leave that too on the push start even it
didn't say
to leave it
this key on the ignition on the push
start button
leave it there until
it says the key registration complete
and that's how you program it guys
and this is a very affordable Key
Program not too bad
all right thank you for watching until
next time
don't forget to like And subscribe
thank you guys